Hey, what's going on? It's bill burn. It's
the Monday morning podcasts from Monday,
November 4th, 2013. How
you doing? How are Ya?
How's it go?
And uh,
you know how fucking red faces
in a good mood this week?
Huh? You know why? Cause it's hockey
season. Nah, I'm fucking with you.
You know what it is?
The Boston Red Sox 2013
world series champions.
And I was there to see it.
Not In person.
I watched it on TV,
you know,
and I've got to tell you all the emotions
I had from jumping on the bandwagon
from game one of the American
League divisional series.
You know what I realized through
watching all that playoff baseball,
I fucking love hockey.
Hockey's is,
I'm really going to say how great the
fucking game is cause I don't want you
guys to watch it because that'll ruin it.
And then somehow hockey players will
be wearing pink in October. All right.
By the way,
I'm loving all those stories that are
coming out about how little money actually
goes to breast cancer research.
Not because I,
I'm pro breast cancer for you need
Yurik fucking conch out there.
It's just because from day one,
if you couldn't see the money
making scam that that was,
and then also on the other side
to try and get more female fence.
Okay. If you can't do the fucking math
on that, you know, the rest of it goes.
Um, so anyways, yeah, the red
sox won it, man. Fantastic.
Hey Seattle,
this is how the song's supposed to go.
We are the champions.
My friends,
I love it.
You know what the best part about the
fucking red sox winning was watching was
Paul Versey immediately sent me
a text and he said, congrats.
And I knew he didn't mean it
and it took about four or five, you
know, it was, it was the red sox parade.
Something happened. And
now Paul Versey. All right?
A New York Yankee fan is now telling
me how arrogant Boston sports fans are.
I mean, I'll listen to that to anybody
else in any other fucking city,
but to hear that from a fucking
Yankee Fan, are you kidding me?
And then he starts bringing up steroids,
a fucking Yankee Finn bringing
up steroids, you know?
Well you wouldn't [inaudible]
fucking stairwell. Really?
You ever think maybe Manny had to do
steroids cause he was facing a roid it up.
Roger Clemens or roid it up.
Andy Pettitte.
Let's go around your infield.
Roid it up. Jason Gmb roid it up.
Fucking a Rod. Oh, now we're
out to the outfield. Roid it up.
Gary Sheffield,
the fucking Yankees from the late nineties
right through the two thousands where
a fucking steroid factory.
If Anna tool to 15 fucking
million dollar team. Jesus Christ.
But I don't begrudge them. I don't
begrudge them any of their fucking titles.
It was the steroid era. Okay?
You knew what Arrow it was.
If you weren't doing steroids,
that's on you. You know,
it's like you're in the music business
and it's the late seventies you don't
want to play disco.
Well have,
have a nice fucking time playing
in front of eight people.
We give Gregorian chant or whatever
the fuck it is you want to do.
It was the steroid era.
I'll tell you right now,
we're all going to fucking be on them.
They're gradually,
gradually going to become legal and all
of this shit that everybody's talking
about them. I look at these fucking
guys, you know I love all these guys,
how they get hurt later on
in their careers and then
they go to Germany and they
like, I don't know what
they're doing over in Germany,
but God knows those fucking maniacs
love experimenting on Human Beings.
These people are coming back.
The Peyton Manning's the Fuck Ed Colby.
Colby is going to come back made out of
titanium and they're going to give all
the credit that that the drive that the
termination of the competitive there
assessed guy has to kill or
attack from Sacha edgery.
I'm telling you right now,
do you want to rewind the clock and come
back like fucking Lee majors and the $6
million man,
you go to fucking Germany.
I don't know what the fuck
they're doing over there.
I had a buddy of mine recently
was talking about the,
they take blood out of here and they
fucking spinning around in this fucking
centrifuge. Oh, is that
what they're doing?
Let me a fucking break.
My fucking leg is killing me because I
ran like two feet down the street the
other day at 45 years of age.
These guys can play tackle football
until 40 I know I'm not a professional
athlete, but I am a
human being. All right?
I'm not going to name any fucking names,
but there's a lot of people do.
When I was a kid,
35 was the breaking point,
and when you were 37 you
were fucking ancient.
People won't even playing chess players
could continue on at 37 golfers,
but that was it. You, you were fucking
dust. It was over. These fucking guys,
you know,
they'll blow out their knee at 41 42
and come back a year later and have a
career fucking year.
Okay.
What did it take us like what a couple
hundred thousand years to walk up, right?
All of a sudden the knee has evolved
that far in fucking 15 years.
I don't know what I'm talking about, but
I'm just saying, all right. Oh my God,
Dude. Versie. I've never seen him whine.
He so fucking pissed at the call
in Boston. Title town. I mean,
what else are you going to call Boston?
Three Superbowls.
Three world series in NBA title.
Get fucked out of another one with
those corrupt refs, but whatever.
We'll give it to them. Yeah,
yeah. Whatever game. Seven cough,
35 files on us and 16 on the other team.
That's fine. That's good. Let's watch a,
when it from the line, um, and
a Stanley Cup championship.
They won eight fucking titles in
10 years with only four teams.
The entire state in New York at this
point. This what does a 10 fucking teams,
New York City next year when
the islanders moved there,
they're going to have two hockey teams,
two basketball teams, two football teams,
two baseball teams, and they've
never had a 10 year run like this.
The fucking Green Bay packers.
If Green Bay Wisconsin could be considered
considered title town in the 60s with
one fucking team, you know? Yeah.
I'd say we earn it. I'm not saying
that throughout all of sports history.
Boston is title town, but right
now, the last 10 fucking years,
be honest with yourself.
Get past your hatred of fucking Boston.
Just look at it on paper. Who,
who would you rather be? You.
Okay.
And the success your team had or,
or what happened in Boston?
I had nothing to do with it.
I'm not being arrogant.
I'm just stating the fucking
facts. All right. And the fact is,
I was watching game was
what the fuck game six.
And at one point,
you know the changing out God damn
pitchers and it's taken for fucking ever.
And I click over to watch a little bit
of the Bruins Penguin's game. And uh,
it was right when they had a fight
right off the face off in the, uh,
the third period.
I forget the guy in the penguins name,
a name of the guy in the pangs of,
he's fucking hilarious.
He's in the middle of the fight and
he's sitting this smiling looking in the
other direction, staying out of the
way. The Bruins guys rights, you know,
you can tell I there's a lot
of new Bruins this year and I,
I've been watching baseball so I got to
get caught up and it was just instantly,
okay,
the fight was over and then we watched
like two minutes of the game and um,
okay.
I fuck it. I'm going to say it.
That game was more exciting.
The game six of the world series.
Maybe it's just me, how I'm wired.
Hockey's it's, I watched the
replay of the, the, the Bruins.
I taped a bunch of Bruins games
and I'm getting caught up.
I watch the Bruins islanders game and
that was a ridiculously fucking exciting
game.
Okay.
Jesus Christ. Thomas Vanek does that
guy fucking own the Bruins are what?
He's killing us.
I got to,
I'm going to try to make it out
by the way to an island is game.
Before they closed that place down,
I'd like to do that and also go to
a 40 niners game. I got it. I mean,
I've been to both places,
but uh, it is the last year.
I haven't been to Nassau Coliseum.
I think I went there in 88 or 89.
Yeah,
I can't.
And I went to a islanders rangers game.
I know I talked about this before,
but uh,
that's a legendary building and I
think it's sad that they're leaving and
they're going to go to
Brooklyn and they're going
to be the Brooklyn Islanders.
I Dunno, I liked it. I,
I've always liked the islanders every
except for when they beat the Bruins and
the, uh, when the fuck did
they be as maybe three now,
83. We choked to the
Canadians somewhere in there.
We met them in the playoffs and I thought
we were going to have a run there.
There was during that their
dynasty. Um, oh, by the way,
I saw some fucking moron.
Red Sox Fan. It said 2004,
2007,
2013 red sox at dynasty.
Who the fuck?
Like
the definition of a dynasty, I swear
to God is like, it's just going,
somebody has to stop it from its free
fall. I remember when the Patriots,
we want three in four years and it was
called the dynasty and that was the first
time. I'm like, wait a minute.
Where dynasties always been,
you have to win three in a row,
200 rows of repeat three is a dynasty.
And then like however long you can
make that go. And I, as far as I know,
my knowledge and professional sports,
I think the record in hockey and baseball
is both five by the Yankees and the
Canadians of course. And, and then in,
let's see, in basketball PSAs,
Celtics with nine, which I mean,
I dunno, I mean it's like
literally the beginning of the NBA.
I look at a lot of that shit.
Um,
you know those championships,
you win in the 23 skidoo years when the
fucking league is just getting started.
You know,
like the League is so new that if you
just walked in with a microphone and a PA
system, you would be the team's fucking
announcer during the game. You know,
those old guys, 80 year old guys,
when they talk about, you know,
how did you get your start? You
know, announcing for the Milwaukee
box,
I saw the paper aren't character one.
I'm Martha phone.
Okay.
I was about four 50 years later.
You know,
like now it's just so it's so locked down.
So there is that weird thing and
it's also, uh, that's, that's,
that's a weird thing about sportswear.
Like each sport has that team
that just went on that fucking run
when the shit was just getting established
and they got so out in front that no
one kicked. Ah, is that really right?
I Dunno. The Lakers caught the Celtics,
which I are catching up to him and I try
to think is the most impressive thing
cause they did it from 1970 [inaudible],
which is basically the free
agent era and all that.
So that's the most impressive one.
Canadians in a maple leafs
when blow for blow 67.
The Celtics are a good example of
it. And um, and the Yankees too,
a little bit of an extent. You know, it's
like they want a ton before, you know,
anybody other than white guys
were allowed to play. But, um,
you can't fuck with going
from Ruth to Gehrig to,
to mantle like no one will ever fuck.
Although,
although the Pittsburgh Penguins,
they're halfway there now. What'd
you say? I guess I wouldn't say that.
Do they went Mario Lemieux Jaromir
Jaga to Gino and fucking Sidney Crosby.
That's pretty impressive. It this day
and age in a, in a 20 year period,
you know Peyton manning to Andrew Luck.
It's just not that. You know what?
It's too early. It's too early to
look back. I Dunno. I Dunno what,
what the fuck am I talking about?
This is the Monday morning podcast,
everybody and uh, uh, what did I do this?
I had a fucking great week.
I'm back out on the road this week
and I'm doing a tuneup show tonight at
flappers out in Burbank.
I going to make sure I give everybody a,
their money's worth this
weekend because coming up,
I got a arguably the biggest
week of shows I've ever had.
I'm at Constitution Hall in Washington
DC and few comedy nerds like myself.
That's where Eddie Murphy tape delirious
and I believe Martin Lawrence. Oh,
still tape to special. There's so, uh,
I got to bring the a game for that one.
Um, and then the next night I'm at the
beacon theater and then the last night,
oh man. Um, I'm in Upper
Darby. People keep saying,
stop saying it's Philly. I mean, to me
it's 15 minutes from downtown Philly,
upper Darby, whatever the
fuck you want to call it. A,
I'm at the tower theater and I'll be
bringing along the most bitter sports fan
that I know in this moment right now.
Paul Versey.
Dude, he was so fucking
mad that the red sox won.
He even brought up the Celtics.
They pile on championship.
Okay.
In 2008,
which I'm always admitted to and I felt
the Kevin Garnett trade should have been
and get investigated considered
Kevin Mchale was like the fucking,
yeah,
whatever it was running shit
for the Timberwolves. Okay.
And I'll list once again,
I'll listen to anybody give me shit about
that. Other than a fucking New Yorker,
he's going to give me shit about buying
a New Yorker is going to give me shit
about buying a fucking championship.
Really 77 78,
Oakland A's slash
fucking New York Yankees.
The 1994 Edmonton Oilers
slash New York Rangers.
Give me a fucking break and then I don't
even need to bring up the Yankees. 99,
2000, 2009. I get the fuck Outta here.
Okay.
Fucking jerk off. Um, anyways,
what am I talking about here? Uh,
yeah, I had, I had an unreal, we,
I gotta I gotta do a little
bit advertising here. Sorry,
I'm a little bit all of them
over the place. I got a,
I got some bullshit I have to do today
before I run over to the club. Um,
I did a benefit last night for a,
for pit bulls down at
Largo and I get admitted.
I was a little fucking out of sorts.
I've been in a weird mood.
I'd just been a joy.
I've been home for like two weeks for the
first two straight weeks in a row this
year. And I got to tell you, I did not
miss going on the road. Kind of scared me,
you know, sat around making Pumpkin
bread and shit wearing a fucking apron.
The hell's wrong with me.
I got to get back out on the road.
I'm going to retire a dollar
shave club. Everybody, uh,
this is this, this one right here
is a, this is killing it right here.
Everybody loves us.
Anybody with whiskers be
you a fucking mail or a,
a hairy woman.
This one is for you.
Dollar Shave Club for a
couple of bucks a month.
Dollar Shave club.com delivers amazing
quality razors right to your door.
Not only does it save you a ton of cash,
but it saves you from trudging to
the drug store for a pack of blades.
I always get stuck behind the lady paying
for all her loose change from the car
ashtray. Is that me supposed
to be saying that now? I don't.
I usually get stuck behind the family
of seven who want to develop pictures,
get some ice cream and also a,
I dunno by some lister mint
Lr Mint Listerine. I don't
know what the fuck it is.
It's like she thinks exact changes
the requirement. Um, anyways,
but with a dollar shave club for
just a couple of bucks a month.
Amazing quality razor blades.
The delivered right to your door people.
That's right. No more wasting
time and no more getting up,
getting hit for 20 bucks.
Every time you buy razors,
everybody here is getting the dollar
shave club blades and you should too.
I should really look at these
before they send these to me, okay?
It's not everybody here. It's
me. It's just me. All right?
Me and my split personality. Uh,
all right, here's a genius idea.
Try replacing your old shaving cream
with Dr Carver's. Easy shave butter,
butter from dollar shave club.com. Trust
me, your face will thank you later.
I've used that stuff. It's great. Uh,
don't waste time at the drug store
behind the lady with paying and Penny's.
Go to dollar shave club.com.
Forward slash bar or go to [inaudible]
dot com and click on the dollar shave
club banner. Keep his stress level low
and your bank account Balance High Shave,
shave time, shave money with dollar
shave club.com. All right, here we go.
He voice. If you are an entrepreneur, hey,
who isn't two things keep you up at night.
Increasing revenue and
controlling expenses.
He voice is a simple technology that helps
you do both. How do you do that? Well,
I'll tell ya,
let's start with revenue.
He voice helps you make sure that everyone
who calls your business is treated
like gold. You get your own toll,
feel toll free or local number.
You can set up a diet,
Jesus Christ,
or you can set up a dial by name
directory or have calls instantly routed
anywhere. Your cell phone, your house,
your partner or assistant
or all of the above,
ie voice even transcribes your voicemails
and emails them to you so you can
prioritize when and how you want to
respond without interrupting your workflow
with He.
You can never leave money on the table.
Just go to the podcast page at [inaudible]
dot com and click on the voice banner
or go to [inaudible]
dot com slash bill burr.
He voice also cut your expenses by acting
as your business phone system and your
receptionist.
This technology could save your business.
Hundreds of thousands of dollars,
he voice starts out and
only 10 bucks per month. Um,
with that you can get plus that,
I'm sorry.
Plus you can get a free
30 day trial right now.
When you go to the podcast page page
at [inaudible] dot com and click on the
voice banner or go to [inaudible] dot
com slash bill birth. That's my website,
[inaudible] dot com and click on the
voice banner or go to [inaudible] dot com
slash Belper all right, let me just
try reading slower in annunciating.
Let me see if this helps me.
Hulu Plus Hulu plus everyone,
you've probably tried
hulu.com now with Hulu plus,
you can watch your favorite shows anytime,
anywhere.
Hulu plus lets you watch thousands of
hit shows and a selection of acclaimed
movies on your television or on the
go with your smartphone or tablet.
And guess what? It all streams in HD for
the best viewing experience with Hulu.
Plus you can watch your favorite current
TV shows like SNL community and family
guy. You could also check out exclusive
content including Hulu originals,
like the awesome starring Snl Seth
Meyers and moon boy starting Chris O'Dowd
from bridesmaids.
Hulu plus also offers a great selection
of a claim films for only 789 a month.
You can stream as many TV
shows and movies as you want,
wherever you want right now.
You can try Hulu plus free for two
weeks when you go to Hulu plus.com/bill
that's a special offer for my listeners.
Make sure you use Hulu plus.com/bill so
you get the extended free trial and the,
and also they'll know that we send you,
go to Hulu plus.com/bill now or
click the Hulu plus banner on the
podcastPage@billbird.com.
Ah,
writing back to the podcast.
All right,
here's one that I've been keeping
an eye on over the last cup.
Oh, by the way, dude, I
tried another, um, you know,
I've been sober here for fucking 13 days.
Um,
I like it.
I like it in the morning.
I hated at night and the morning I want
to hug somebody, but at night I, uh,
you know, I dunno what I want to do,
but I want to inflict pain on somebody.
So I been just been trying
to fill up those times with
some that I used to booze.
Uh, and I'm not done forever
people, I'm coming back. All right.
Just like Marianna Rivera,
I'm coming back.
Um,
I tried,
I tried to make homemade Ravioli
for the first time. Okay.
And like an asshole rather than just
trying to make the homemade Ravioli and
making a simple ricotta filling,
just keeping it simple like that or
maybe just make an a sketti right.
What is old Billy fuck face too?
He tries to make a braised short rib
Ravioli with this mushroom gravy on top.
It was like trying to
make three fucking entrees
by myself. I already knew how
to make braised short ribs,
so I had to go through that whole fucking
process just to get the filling for
the Ravioli that I had never made.
So for the first time in my life,
my mother bought me one of those
kitchen aid mixes like seven years ago,
and I have never used it.
The fucking thing weighs more
than the god Damn Stanley Cup.
And I finally took this thing out of the
back of my poor excuse for a pantry and
I set it down and I had the pasta making,
uh,
attachment and a, I can't even
tell you how fucking excited I was.
So I watched the Sicilian woman, I'll
send you the link to it when she makes,
she makes this homemade
pasta semolina with her.
Fucking perfect. Did she just
look at her? She's, she's,
she's from Sicily.
Sound like she's Sicilian and she's
lived over here for a couple of,
I'll just show it to you. When you
look at her Fred Sanford fucking hands,
you know that she's been needing pasta
dough since the day she came out of the
womb and she knew what the
fuck she was doing. So the pot,
the doe actually came out.
All right.
I probably should have needed it a little
bit more, but I didn't have that. Um,
they'll Ravioli thing where you,
it's like you're,
you're like a notary republic
and you got to stamp it down.
So I make the fuck and I
make the fucking Ravioli.
It actually came out really good.
I could have mixed it a little bit more.
There's a little bit of granulated Samuel
Semolina so I kind of fucked it up a
little bit.
And then I put my filling in,
they're caramelized onions with braised
short ribs and a little bit of carrots
in there.
Fucking delicious sticking in this shit.
And I go to make these stinks and
I fucked up on two levels. One,
I didn't seal them correctly and two,
I made them too big.
Okay.
Cause I guess when you drop them in the
water when they're done is when they
float.
But mine was so big they will like fucking
barges and they would just floating
up top and they weren't
sealed and all the fuck
all the fucking filling came out of him.
And um,
it was a fucking mess.
It was an absolute fucking mess.
And Ah, I almost started crying.
It took me like that entire process
took about five and a half hours.
It took me three hours to
fucking braised short ribs,
get all the ingredients, braised
short ribs and it fucking Dutch oven.
And it just, I, I wa I didn't, you
know what? I didn't waste a day.
You learn something in your failures.
I know how to caramelized onion.
I know how to fucking reduce that God
damn sauce down to a fucking gravy.
The douche bag with the youtube video,
the you edited the shit together.
You made it seem like that took five
minutes. Should I sit or already started?
Saute my mushrooms?
You can't.
And you're fucking left half
of the ingredients off of
your shit because you won
that cook and contest with
it. All right. And I get it.
You want to be a celebrity chef so you
don't want to tell all your fucking
secrets.
So why don't you put up a recipe of,
of PB and j next time instead of having
this vague thing and having me waste my
whole fucking Saturday.
You conk Africanus all right.
So anyways, but a homemade
pasta, not that hard to do a,
I'm going to do it again tonight.
Picking myself up off the Mat.
Unlike George Foreman, when Molly got
knocked him down back in the day, right?
I'm getting up,
I'm coming out.
I'm going to try spaghetti tonight,
making it nice and simple. All right,
I've got to prego sauce. I don't give a
fuck. I'm keeping, I'm working at one,
working on my pasta game tonight and
that'll be easy. I got the attachment.
He just,
you know,
send it through number one a couple
of times and then to then up to three,
I think,
and then I'll put the fucking sketti
attachment on and I'll send it right
through the fucker. And that's going
to be it. That's what I'm hoping.
Jesus Christ, what happened to me. You
know what happened? I stopped drinking.
That's what happened when I
stopped drinking. All right?
The booze goes away and the
apron comes out of the drawer.
Oh, hey, by the way, do you know we
didn't celebrate Halloween this year?
I was really, uh, that was nias
call because of all the, uh,
all the fucking assholes who came to
our house last year who were well beyond
the age of being able to trick or treat.
So instead we went to the clippers
warriors game and a what a fucking team.
The warriors half man.
I'm actually thinking about getting the
fucking NBA package cause I don't watch
enough sports.
Right.
MMM.
It was ridiculous.
That's the fucking game was like,
it was like an all star game as far as
the, it wasn't like one 20 something,
the one 20 something.
Um,
but I could tell you we went to the
game and being stone sober at a game and
just taking in the level
of mouth breathing,
fucking drunk morons that go to the game.
That was really eyeopening.
MMM.
I used to sit in there like, wow, that,
that guy is me except I'm sober right now.
I watched this drunk fat couple in front
of me get hammered out of their minds
and then order this big thing and Nachos
and then feed them to each other like
this. Like they were
in lady. And the tramp.
It's one of the most disgusting
things I've ever seen.
But like if I was hammered, I would've
been like all look at their in love.
So I'm basically, I'm going to
try and stay sober until, uh,
until I go over to Europe and then
all bets are off all bets. I mean,
like I'm going to go to Italy and I'm
not going to fucking drink some wine.
Give me a fucking break. Right. Anyways,
and speaking over there in Europe,
this is a story that I've been keeping
up on is the, uh, the Greenpeace 30.
Okay.
The Greenpeace sturdy.
Now for those of you who haven't been
paying at paying attention or, uh,
having listened to the
podcast really quickly,
it was a group of 28 greenpeacers,
is that the correct word?
Greenpeace people and uh,
and to journalists. And they decided
that they were going to board
a Russian oil rig five basically somehow
shooting their ropes up there and
climbing up the side of it.
And they got arrested by Russian Navy
seals and they would charge with piracy as
you would think that they would.
And they've all been, you know,
all the Greenpeace supporters
and their family members.
They're all outrage thinking that
the Russians are overreacting.
And, uh, and when we last saw them,
let me click on this.
When we last saw them,
they were in a jail in Murmansk
Russia, which at this time, a year,
it's dark, 24 hours. And, uh,
and they were actually going to drop
the piracy charges from piracy down to
hooliganism. But, uh, this
is what's happened this week.
Arctic 30 being moved from
Murmansk to Saint Petersburg.
St Petersburg is out of the Arctic
circle and now you're basically right,
just south of Finland.
Um,
and I want to say that that's the city
that Finland had to give back to the
Russians, even though they
beat him and World War II,
they had to give him back just
because they sided with the, uh,
angry Charlie Chaplin over there. Um,
alright. Amsterdam, November 1st, 2013,
Greenpeace international understands,
uh,
from diplomatic sources that the 30 men
and women detained in Russia following a
peaceful protest. That's what they
said. Peaceful protest. Yeah. Like that.
There was nothing peaceful about that.
It was somewhere between
peaceful and an act of war.
As far as I'm concerned.
You just don't go out into international
waters and just without permission
boards,
somebody else's vehicle.
He can't do shit like
that. Yeah. All right.
But they consider it a peaceful protest,
uh,
against an Arctic oil platform and are
being moved from a detention center in
Murmansk to a jail in Saint Petersburg.
You like how they completely ignore
the fact that they tried to board the
fucking thing.
It's not like they just showed up and
kind of drove around it with signs saying,
hey man, fucking knock it off. Uh,
lawyers for Greenpeace are not
aware of the reasons for the move.
Greenpeace international executor
directive Kumi nine idle said, uh,
that the detainees, this is what the PR,
that's cool. Me Person said that today,
any shouldn't be in jail at all.
They should be free to join their
families and restart their lives.
St Petersburg has some
daylight in the winter months,
unlike Murmansk families and counts and
consular officials will now find it easy
to visit the 30.
But there is no guarantee t
that conditions inside the
new detention center will
be any better than in Murmansk. In fact,
they could be worse. There is no justice,
there's no justification whatsoever to
keep the Arctic 30 in prison for four a
day longer.
I love that.
They just completely ignore
that they broke the law.
I don't know what law it is.
I'm completely uninformed,
but I know you just can't
go around boarding other
countries. Fucking oil play.
I wouldn't even do that to excellence.
And they were allegedly
on my team anyways.
They are prisoners of conscience who
acted out of determination to protect us
all. And they should be free
now that I don't disagree with,
but the way you fucking went
about it. Um, so here's the thing.
Greenpeace today released photographs,
blah, blah blah. So as a last week they,
they allegedly drop the piracy charges,
but um,
I guess they're saying they haven't.
Now all they've done is
tacked on hooligan charges.
So they nan now stand as of right now,
they now stand accused of both offenses,
which carry a maximum sentence
of 15 years for piracy.
And seven years for hooliganism
respectively. All right. So
I dunno,
I don't disagree with Greenpeace
of that type of thing,
but I hope that they learned that,
you know, you can't just go around
boarding Russian oil platforms
and just because you know,
it's a peaceful, I mean, Jesus Christ,
I mean that's like, I dunno, somewhere
in there there's a protest is,
is that gray area between a
protest and an act of war.
Like that shit that's going on
between China and Japan right now,
they're fighting over those islands.
Okay.
I forget who said somebody going to
shoot down another person's drones and a,
the other countries going to consider
it a fucking act of war if they do it.
I gotta tell you,
man,
that that will be fucking insane
if Japan and China go at it.
Okay.
Who Do you like?
Who Do you like in that dog fight?
Let's just say for once the United States
stays out of it and Russia stays out
of it, and if the two of them
were just going to throw it out,
I would just think sheer numbers.
China has to have them.
They got to have.
Yeah.
You know,
and those islands are closer to China,
so that's more a home
field advantage for them.
I don't know.
Is it weird that I want to see it?
Okay.
That's fucked up, right? I'm
just sick of like, you know,
it's like when the Yankees
and red sox played each other,
like to the point they just pat each
other, play each other for 30 years.
I got burned out in that rivalry and
I just wanted to watch somebody else.
I started watching the royals.
I am sick of watching the fucking
the u s go at it with everybody.
I want to watch Japan powers.
Watch two other countries have
a nice fucking throw down.
I want to see it pay per view.
Japan versus China. Who Do you like?
Yeah.
You know, technicians versus
fucking smash mouth football.
Okay.
All right.
Enough with me sounding fucking stupid.
Trying to talk about international shit.
Okay.
I had a dream come true this week.
Everybody,
aside from watching just Paul Versey.
Oh my God.
Was he a fucking baby?
He was pulling out all
the stops last night.
He fucking hates Boston.
And then he tried to tell me all the
reasons why he loved Boston to justify his
hatred of Boston.
You know,
he basically gave me the sports analogy
of the classic. No, no, no. Wait,
my best friend is African American. That's
what he did. But he did it in a sports,
you know, it was fucking horrific to
people who've funny. They like to food.
Shut the F stop trying to
give yourself credibility. Um,
please, please listen to the Paul versus,
uh, podcasts Diversey effect this week.
I'm sure he's going to be going off.
If you're as a red sox fan,
you should really listen to them.
You got to listen to him piss and Moan
about their beards and all of that shit.
It's going to be,
it's just going to be fucking
music to my goddamn years.
And all he does is he just brings up the
fact that the giants beat the Patriots
twice. I don't give a fuck. We
still won three super bowls.
I would rather,
who would you rather fucking be?
And I'm not giving all New York fans shit.
I'm just talking specifically diversity.
Um,
and anybody else there who's a whiny
fucking cunt who God knows I'm a hypocrite
because I've been a whiny cunt about
the Lakers and the Yankees and every,
the Canadians. It's just fun to be on
the other side of the wine. If, um,
and now I get to act like
I'm a fucking perfect person,
um, yeah, I am a hypocrite.
Go Fuck Yourself. I stand by it. Anyways,
the other dream that had come through
is I've been, I've been gradually, uh,
for like I would say,
I don't know,
whenever Mike Johnston started
doing those drum lessons,
whenever I stumbled upon them,
I was still living in New York,
I believe when I first found them
back in like, oh seven or whatever.
And um,
you know,
I found these drum lessons online and I
just kept going from guy to guy to guy.
And then I stopped at this guy,
Mike Johnston,
and he was just head and shoulders above
everybody else that I saw it there.
And the and the stuff that he was
teaching and the way broke it down and his
whole philosophy,
the whole pattern speed movement,
the whole fucking thing that
he did was just, I don't know,
it just really connected with me. So
for years I was thinking, you know,
some point I'm going to see that guy
either at a clinic and I'm going to take,
you know, maybe take a lesson, one of
the other blah blah blah blah blah.
Long story short,
he came down to the new recessed
studios in Santa Ana, California,
which is right down in
Orange County, California.
If you play in a band and you
don't want to play in some grimy,
horrific rehearsal space,
like most of them are with like fucking
stains on the rug from grand funk
railroad 40 fucking years earlier
when they weren't even famous. Uh,
if you want to plan an just state
of the art awesome facility,
recessed studios in Santa Ana,
California. Anyways, long story short,
I guess the guy who opened the place was
one of Mike Johnson's drum students and
he was talking about opening a
rehearsal place and Mike said, well,
if you ever opened one, I'll come
down for free and do a drum clinic.
So that's how I ended up going down there.
And I reached out to Mike and he goes,
hey, why don't you come down and take a
fucking lesson? He didn't say fucking,
he's much more classy guy than I am.
And I got to knock that out. And uh,
it was the shit.
So I'm sober,
I'm cooking and I took drum lessons
from a fucking drum God this week.
And now I have to go back to fuck at
lax tomorrow where somebody shot up a
fucking tee at TSA agent
and I have been a grumpy cunt
on stage by last two shows.
I'm getting nervous. Everybody,
I think I'm getting old.
I'm getting too old to do the fucking
road. I got to, I, you know what?
I got to go to Germany, like Peyton
manning and those guys I, I need,
I need to fucking get up.
Have them spin my blood
around some centrifuge or
whatever the fuck you call it.
But anyways, I'm getting off track.
So thank you to Mike Johnston,
unbelievably patient,
uh,
dealing with my drum and in and helping
me try and improve. And if you don't,
if you play drums or whatever,
I highly recommend going
to a Mike's lessons.com.
And um, he, I mean he's just state of the
art. You can Skype in and watch the guy,
you know, do live lessons is just like,
he is at the forefront of all of that.
And on top of all of that,
he's a phenomenal drummer
and we'll break down any,
basically if you can get in touch
with them, anything that he did,
he'll break it down as slow as you
want. He's just, he's the shit.
So that was my weekend with
that. With that, let me, uh,
let me, um, oh, and also something else.
I'm not going to say who it
was, but uh, someone else,
I know a has one of those,
those cars,
Tesla's and I got to
drive one and ride in one.
It was the fastest fucking car I've
ever been in. It's a 100% electric.
So all you guys who wrote all that
homophobic shit about my Prius. No, that,
my Prius is actually a gas combustion
engine past five miles an hour.
It's a big fucking scam.
It's only electric from five and
a five miles an hour and under.
But this was actually a full on
electric car and it was fucking insane.
The back of my head was tingling.
I think that was blood going
to the back of my head.
We got up to 60 miles an hour so god damn
fast and he didn't even have the fast
one. He had I guess the
slower version of it. And uh,
you can drive from San Diego all the way
up to the border of Canada in charge.
The car right now, it takes 30 minutes
to charge it. You can go 350 miles.
Most of the charges I
guess during rest areas,
he just sit down and you have something
to eat. Check your fucking messages.
I know it's 30 minutes,
but whatever you pull into a gas station,
you get a slim Jim, you go in there, you'd
take a shit. Right. That's 10 minutes.
Which I,
you know what the one thing I didn't
ask was how much the electricity costs?
I have no idea,
but I guess a,
their goal is you're going to be
able to hopefully by 2014 drive from
Los Angeles to New York City. But, uh,
I don't know if you got the money because
they're not cheap. Dude. It was insane.
I wanted to,
I guess all the batteries are under the
car and I wanted to look under and see
him and the guy was like,
well,
it's going to look like a skateboard
underneath the car. And uh,
it was insane. I, there was a couple of
things that he said and I forgot to ask.
He said, there's no fluid in the car.
And I'm thinking, all right, well,
it's all batteries so you don't need
to, uh, you don't need any antifreeze.
You don't need any oil. There's no
transmission, no transmission fluid.
But I forgot to ask him about the braking
system. You got to have brake fluid,
right? You know, it's funny as I could
just probably look it up, but, uh,
if you get a chance,
definitely check those things out.
And this guy was telling me that there's
people that drag strips that'll take
like to some guy,
he has a Datsun,
just a regular old Datsun from the 70s.
It's all electric power and he fucking
wings in the quarter mile drag races all
the time, all the, all the, all the time,
which makes me feel great because for
years I defended the Prius and electrical
power by saying you can get on a subway
and that can move a thousand people
at like 35, 40 miles an hour
during rush hour in New York City.
You think of fucking car.
If they really wanted to make
one with electrical power,
couldn't be fast while I finally
experienced it. So, uh, I dunno,
I'm really battling this week.
Uh, let's, let's get to the, uh,
let's get the questions for this week.
A pumpkin bread. Hey, Billy Crocker.
Tell us something exciting about the
Pumpkin bread making experience as if you
were doing sports center coverage of
what went down during the process. Dude,
what is this like a fucking Improv class?
I Dunno.
I Dunno what to tell you. I already
told you about the disaster. I my,
you know what I did? I
already did it with my, my,
my braised short rib Ravioli.
That was like talking about the red
collapse in September last year.
That's as close as I'm going to
get. And A, I don't know, we gotta,
we gotta switch it up this week with
a bunch of international emails.
Take a break from the relationship advice.
Listen to this one.
This one's from Peru.
Dear Billie holiday,
I am from Peru and I love your comedy.
I wish I could say Peru loves you,
but I haven't met many
people who have heard of you.
I think you should come in for form
here. Well, what the fuck? Toe.
Okay. If you, I'm to you,
why don't you just have a birthday
party and I'll fly down there,
take me to a soccer game and I'll do stand
up and I'll bomb in front of all your
relatives.
Um,
as they stare at me and my lack of pigment
anyways, nobody knows me down there,
but for some reason I should
go there and perform. He says,
but I don't know how many people
would understand your humor. He said,
he said a gold digging whore would be
a good thing here because it would mean
she gave out sex. And also what's
so bad about a girl who digs,
digs for gold? That's been an, that's
better than a girl that doesn't, you know,
I forgot you guys actually have mines
down there and that's actually it. Job,
you know, for an individual rather
than a giant machine. Uh, anyways,
he says that's what people here
would think. Don't feel bad though,
because I think the most people
here don't know who bill Cosby is.
Listen, if I somehow could get
through Rosetta stone Spanish
and, uh, learn how to speak your language.
If you think I wouldn't come down to
Peru, I'd actually would read up. I mean,
do you guys hate us down there too?
I believe,
don't feel like getting kidnapped by
some sort of rebel group and I hate to
admit it,
but to me that's what a lot of South
America is because that's what I see.
I see all the, you know, killing
Pablo. I read that book. I probably,
I probably haven't read a lot of good
things about South America. Yeah,
it's cocaine cowboys.
It's a Nazi war criminals.
Yeah.
It's um, the most perfect
asses in the world in Brazil.
And uh,
I dunno,
I don't know what else it is.
It's the Galapagos silence
that's arrested abroad. It's
the hand to God. Shocker.
Move by. That fucking guy.
Was it Vince Ferragamo?
I don't know a lot about down there.
I'd love to go though. You know,
if I could go down there and you could
guarantee that I wouldn't get kidnapped,
I wouldn't get stabbed because it's some
horrific shit that we do in our foreign
policy down there. I would definitely
go down there. I've been to Costa Rica.
That's the closest I ever, I forgot
to uh, to South America, but um,
that is on my bucket list to [inaudible].
I want to go to all the continents
other than a Antarctica. I don't want,
I have no reason to fucking
go there. All right. Anyways,
let me know you guys open an English
speaking comedy club down there. I'll,
I'll fly down there. It's a
promise. All right. From Dublin.
All right there. Billy red boy,
a big fan, blah, blah, blah.
I only recently found out about your
podcast and been listening to them instead
of the depressing shit that's
played on our radio station. Dude,
the difference in work,
my work days from listening to your
comedy and laughing my ass off in the car
was immense.
The urge to punch some of my managers
I have to deal with on a daily basis.
It turned has turned from a vein popper
to just saying go fuck yourself in my
head and laughing in their faces.
So thank you for that and keep it up.
Can't wait for the Dublin Gig.
I've got tickets that I'm going to bring
a date so it's gonna be a great night.
Thanks for penciling us in on your tour.
I'll buy you a pint.
Okay.
In Vicar Street. Go Fuck
Yourself. All right. That was
just sort of a love letter.
There's really no advice there. Uh,
well now that you brought it up,
I got to do my, I got to give you my
dates here for the big European tour.
When I fall off the wagon, I'm going
to fall off hard when I'm over there.
I already got some drinking buddies in
England that I met the last time I was
over there and one other friend
that's coming down from Scotland.
So right there, you know,
that's going to go to a,
what the hell are we shows?
Bang right there. Uh,
though, due to do the first
one, December 4th, Glasgow,
Scotland, December 5th, I'm in Amsterdam.
December 7th. I'm at the forum in
London for three shows. Oh wait,
I'm sorry. December 8th. Um, and
also with the forum in London.
So one of those nights, I'm doing
two shows, three total. December 9th,
I'm at Vicar Street, a Dublin, Ireland.
December 10th them at the
[inaudible] theater in Helsinki,
Finland to shows December 11th,
I met the Bremen theater in Copenhagen,
Denmark on December 12th.
I can't even read the name
in Oslow Norway. They'll,
they'll full key t tenor red folk,
etc. I don't know what the fuck that is.
I met the circus in Stockholm,
Sweden on December 13th
and on December 15th, um,
at the Silverberg Hall and Rick Avik,
Reykjavik, however you
saved Iceland. There you go.
Yeah.
And I'm going to be boozing it up,
flying solo.
I usually travel with
the lovely Nia, but, uh,
she's done that run with me a number
of times. She's a trooper. I mean,
you can see that's just like a, uh,
that is definitely a thrash. But, um,
she's coming with me to Italy.
We're going to have a good time over
there and then I'm flying off and she's
going to stay in Italy with some friends.
His daddy goes out and make some fucking
money. All right? That's how it works. Um,
all right,
let's get back to do the final
advertising reads here. All right.
Legal Zoom. Every one, legal zoom.
There are two reasons why now is the
perfect time to start your business.
Reason number one, the economy is
picking up and the longer you wait,
the longer you delay
your potential success.
Reason to right now you can
incorporate your business or form an
llc@legalzoom.com for just $99 legal
zooms online process guides you step by
step and you can get total
customer support. They
couldn't make it much easier.
Legal Zoom provides self help services
at your specific direction and can
connect you to an attorney, but they are
not a law firm, so save a pile of money.
Oh, so you save a pile of money, get
an extra discount. When you went to B,
you are are in the
referral box at checkout.
Don't wait on the sidelines while others
are taking charge of their futures.
Now is the best time to get in
the game and launch your business.
Don't put this off for incorporation,
trademarks, patents, and more.
Just go to legalzoom.com right now.
Discount Code birth.
That's legalzoom.com
discount, discount code, Burr,
stamps.com everyone the classic.
Here we go,
stairs.com think about how many hours
you've had to waste or I'm thinking about
how many hours you've had to waste
going to the post office for business,
for your business, driving their parking,
waiting for the next available clerk.
There's nothing I can do to
get those hours back for you,
but I can't save you time moving forward
with stamps.com stamps.com brings all
the services of the U S Postal
Service right to your desk.
24 seven buy and print official us postage
using your own computer and printer
stamps.com we'll send you a digital scale
and it instantly calculates exact the
exact postage for any letter or package,
any class of male. There's no guesswork.
It's easy.
Then just hand your mailed in a mail man
and you'll never waste time at the post
office ever again.
I use stamps.com to send out all my DVDs,
my posters, whatever the hell it is. I'm
trying to get to the thing, the Giga,
whatever, if I can use it. If a
more unlike me, configure it out.
Thank God knows you can't to right now.
Use My last name.
Birth for this special offer.
No risk trial plus $110 bonus offer that
includes a digital scale and up to $55
free postage. Don't wait. Go to
stamps.com before you do anything else,
click on the
microphone@thetopofthepageofthehomepageandtypeinburburthatstamps.com
enter
burr
and finally vista print.
What is Vista print you ask yourself?
[inaudible] it's a business card that
says a lot about you and your business.
Uh,
what this toppy makes no sense.
Let me start over again. I'm just
going to read it the way they wrote it.
Take to vista print.
A business card says a lot
about you and your business.
Are you a hardworking landscaper,
a hip and funky salon owner,
a loyal dog, Walker, no matter what you
are or what kind of business you have.
vistaprint.com has thousands of
designs to just say what you want.
And today we just got word of a
great offer on their business cards.
Get 250 of their premium
cards for only 10 bucks.
I'm the shipping is is
on them to good Lord.
10 Bucks for 250 business cards to Christ.
They given it away. I created my cards.
The other, no, I didn't stop
putting words in my mouth.
I didn't create any cards but I'm
going to cause it's only $250 a month.
It's a great, it's a great
deal. I don't need the lie.
Vista prints has so many
designs to choose from that you,
that your bond to find that you're bound
to find one of these that says just
what you want. Uh, once you find the card,
you like design the process itself.
It's easy and it's fun. Ad Text,
photos of logos, and you can
change colors, fonts, and
move things around. So again,
that's 250 high quality business
premium cards with shipping included.
For only 10 bucks.
Go to www.vistavistaprint.com.
Click on the herd of us on radio TV
button in the upper right hand corner and
put in the promotional code, bird
bird. Good Lord. As you check out,
make sure you take a look at the
other marketing products they offer,
like postcards, flyers,
brochures, and websites.
They can even match your business card.
Get 250 premium business cards for
only 10 bucks, including the shipping.
Just go to www.vistaprintdot.com
click on click on the heard of us.
I give up.
Click on the herd of us TV radio button
in the upper right hand corner and put
in the promotional code burr.
You know what?
I'm going to hire somebody to read
these things for me. All right?
Somebody with a nice sexy
fucking voice and I'll, I'll be,
I'll be equal opportunity. Male,
female, straight, gay. We like,
we gotta do something about these
reeds. Okay, I can't read them.
And now they're trying to do this,
this phony, put in a personal touch.
Like I'm using all of these products.
Okay.
I believe in all of these products,
but I don't use all of them. All right?
I'm only one man. I can't use
everything out there. All right,
here we go. Let's get back to the
reeds for this week. What are we up to?
53 K, excruciating minutes.
Military origins story.
Billy boy,
I am a military vet and wanted to share
a story with you seeing as you like
military history and by no means an
expert and this is probably all bullshit,
but this is how the legend goes. I love
our, I already love how this story starts.
Um,
your whole setup of this is what 99% of
the shit that comes out of my mouth can
be defined us.
I'm no expert,
and this is probably bullshit,
but this is my opinion because I
overheard this from somebody in a mall.
Uh,
back in Vietnam,
there was a guy named
Colonel Robin olds who is,
who was commander of a fighter squadron.
He was a triple ace.
I don't know what that means.
Does that mean he killed three people
or fought in three wars or read three
different ways of killing you in the air?
I have no idea, but he was a triple A's.
I'm going to use that next
time I'm drinking in a bar.
Some woman gives me shit.
I'll be all happy. No, I'm a triple ace.
What does that mean? You'll figure it out.
Uh, he was a triple ace and fought in
World War II and would later retire as a
general.
Good Lord.
Any one of those things is beyond anything
I've accomplished in my entire life.
Uh,
olds grew a mustache while overseas in
defiance of the air force regulations are
righties. A red sock. Yeah, that fuzzy.
And he's a triple ace.
We are, the champions.
Old's grew a mustache while overseas in
defiance of the air force regulations
and command. I commit and
commanded his men to grow one,
two on the basis that it
makes you bulletproof.
One of his more men refuse
to do so because he, he,
he felt that look retarded
and got shot down.
He was recovered and grew a mustache
and wasn't shot down again before this.
Ms. This,
why all these studly guys throughout
the years would always have fucking
mustaches before hipsters
ruined them. Uh, before,
before this guy went home,
he shaved his mustache and
got shot down a second time.
It is now a tradition for flyers
to grow mustaches overseas.
It's such a superstition that schedulers,
we'll make sure at least one on the
crew has a mustache and avoid making a
as a mustache and avoid Ellen and they
avoid making all female crews. Well,
what about Tom Cruise? He didn't
have a mustache, but goose dead.
A ghost did he got hit by the canopy?
Well, that's Hollywood. That's not
real war. All right. This grow into it.
The tradition of mustache march
in the air force where everyone,
regardless of whether they fly or not,
gross mustaches,
this intern evolved into Movember's
where men grow mustaches or no shave
November where men grow beers to raise
awareness for prostate cancer and other
male cancer and associated charities
during the month of November.
So go grow a mustache.
You pasty freckled fuck.
Okay.
Thanks for the free
laughs. Um, I will look, I,
I'm aware of prostate cancer.
All right.
I guess I should grow
one so I never get it.
I've grown mustaches and the PR in
the, I don't know, I'm a contrarian.
I can never go to the fucking way. That's
actually a really interesting story.
I hope even 8% of that
was true by the way.
Who was this guy who got shot down?
That's where it all falls apart.
And then the one there was a guy is,
that's how most of the urban myths
start. But I like it. Great Story.
And I stand by your complete lack of
research because that's everything that I
do. All right. From Finland, we're
going around going around Europe,
here from Finland. Hi. Hello
there. William F Birrer.
I'm a 22 year old guy from Finland,
Finland and I've waited a long
time for you to do a show here.
So I'm very excited to hear you're
coming to Helsinki and December.
Unfortunately, because of my
studies, I'm doing a practical,
I'm doing a practical training
in Africa for three months,
so I'm going to miss the show.
I hope I will one day have the money
to come see your show in the u s so I'm
going to Ghana in a group of four students
and I'm the only guy in the group.
I'll be in the same house and going
to the same workplace with the,
these three ladies for three months.
We all know each other quite well,
but I'm mostly used to hang out with guys.
So if you'd give me some advice or tips
on how to mentally prepare for these
three months,
it would be greatly appreciated.
Are there some topics are actions
I should make sure to avoid?
Thanks and go fuck yourself.
Ps,
love the podcast and all that other stuff.
I hope to see more in Tva. That's
very nice. What a nice email. Um,
are there some topics?
Listened to the amount of things
I've fucked up with women.
All I can tell you is what not to do.
Um,
all right.
This is what I would do if I was you.
The first thing you got to do is if
you're a type a male on any level,
you gotta tone that shit
down. Oh, if you're angry,
all anger does is scare women,
okay.
Or makes them not want to be around you
or it makes women who have daddy issues,
uh,
you know,
okay.
It's like a moth to a fucking light except
the moth reaches in, grabs your heart,
pulls it out of your chest and
throws it down the stairs. Um,
if you're going to live
with these three women,
okay,
all right.
This is what you could do.
Are a trying to fuck these women or are
you just trying to get along with them?
All right, first things first, uh,
make sure you're really neat.
Okay.
Granted,
you know,
women in the bathroom of some of the
messiest fuckers on the planet, but a,
I would do that.
I would come with slumber party energy
and just fucking given to their fucking
conversations, okay? And right there is
where you establish credit credibility.
You're not angry,
you keep your part of the bathroom clean.
And you come with all my God,
you got you.
You fucking give into that fucking energy
late at night when they want to snack
and they're fucking jam jams,
you join them.
Okay.
All right.
And you never try to fuck any of them.
Okay.
Then what you'd do is you'd talk to
them about how you're having problems
meeting women in Ghana and you need
advice and then there'll become a fucking
wing man for you and you'll be crushing
fucking Gannon East fucking ass.
Whatever the hell you want to call it.
Right and left when you're out there
and they'll actually help you do it.
Okay.
That's, that's, that
would be my game plan.
But the last thing you should do is
try to hook up with any one of them and
unless it's the last weekend,
the last weekend comes around,
all bets are off.
You get in there and you fuck them all.
Yeah.
Somewhere in there is probably some
information that you could use.
If anybody has any suggestions on what
this guy should be doing. My, my, uh,
my trip isn't until December if anybody
else's studied abroad with three broad
and has better advice.
Yeah.
Um, for the love of God, let me know
and I'll pass it onto this, this, uh,
this, uh, this, this, this fine
young gentleman. All right.
Documentaries. Uh, just a
bill on Capitol Hill. Ah,
one of my favorites.
I know a lot of you guys are too
old to remember schoolhouse rock.
Do you remember that?
I'm just a bill. Yes.
I'm only a bill and I'm sitting
here on Capital Hill where
I put all the bank as I saw that
and I bought out a [inaudible] la.
How bad. Sorry. That was way too long.
Pray that I will. But today
I'm still just a bill. Um, Hey,
your top school house rocks.
Yeah.
Three is a magic number.
Okay.
Conjunction junction verb.
That's what's happening.
I'm just a,
Bill's a great one.
Number nine is a great one.
Okay.
Oh my God. I'm going to have
to fucking upload that Shit.
I have that on CD box set somewhere.
Jesus under some championship hat.
Okay.
Roberta did. All right. I've got two
documentaries for your, your red face,
um,
to lock onto.
Yeah.
All right. First up black fish. This
is about killer whales and sea world.
Basically,
it starts from the time they got a
killer whale into cap into captivity.
I really apologize for
my reading out loud.
This is like the worst I've
ever done. Um, anyways,
he says this is about,
basically it starts from the first
time they got a killer whale into cap
captivity at seaworld.
They separate it from its mother at the
age of two males remained with their
mothers their whole lives.
So the separation is very traumatic.
They are kept in tanks too
small and fed very little.
The whole thing is mindblowing. It aired
on CNN and I recommend it to everyone.
You won't believe the stuff that comes
out of the seaworld employees mouse.
Oh, though I might just take your, uh,
your word on that.
I can't handle watching people do stuff,
uh,
animals and kids.
And then the next level,
like the level of rage because
that's about as innocent as it gets.
And then the next level of rage
above that is, is someone you know,
beating the shit out of their
girlfriend and a wife or anything.
Like I can't handle watching that stuff.
Like they made that thing, what was it,
the cove
where they just drive all those dolphins
into that little area and then they
just bludgeoned them to death. Like just
tell me where I need to donate money.
I really can't watch like last night,
this is my second time doing that
pit bull thing in one of the pit,
the woman who organizes it has a,
has a pit bull herself and
has a scar on his back,
cause some Douche bag dump
battery acid on the thing. And uh,
I showed up late to it this year hoping
I avoided the story cause I knew that
someone was going to ask and I showed up
and someone asks and I had to listen to
it again and it just fucking,
I swear to God I could literally kill
somebody. I don't know if I could do that,
but I could do some horrific
blow torch shit to them. Um,
so I'll watch as much as that is.
I can,
if it's on Netflix, I'll try and
pull it up a second. Dirty wars.
This follows a loan.
Journalists who tracks the origins of a
drone strike from Afghanistan to Yemen.
It's streaming on Netflix
or I'll watch this.
Those drones fascinate the shit out of me.
Uh,
if this aired on network television,
there would be riots in the streets over
what our military is doing in the name
of the u s all right. But I'm also going
to watch it knowing that this is, I mean,
is this,
is this a documentary or is this like
one of those Michael Moore documentaries
where it's really an op Ed
piece? Um, I'll watch it.
I'll watch it. Fuck it. A dirty war.
Dirty wars correlates with the news
coming out about Obama claiming to be good
at killing people to his aides.
Here's an article from a Yahoo.
I'll give you guys this link.
Um,
I'm not co sign in on any of
this shit until I see it. Uh,
Jesus, man, do you have
a happy one in there?
Is there one about an old lady making
her own her own jam and a beaten out the
corporations. You gotta give me a
little, you got to give me a ray of Sun.
I appreciate all of that stuff.
I'm going might have to watch dirty wars.
I'm going to, I know I'm gonna have to,
I'm going to watch both of those. Fucking
okay.
Jesus Christ.
Hey,
how about now that he's given me two
that's going to make me lose even more
faith in humanity and uh, and I'm not
saying I'm better than these people.
I'm a complete piece of shit
myself. But, uh, can, can I get,
can I get a good one in there?
Yeah.
Uh,
it,
does anybody have a documentary on
Iceland standing up to the bankers that I
could watch because
that one fascinates me.
MMM.
And how that wasn't covered
that much here in the states.
I would love to see
that one. Um, all right,
so here's the wrap up everybody.
Now that the show is over,
don't forget to sign up for
your free trial of Hulu.
Plus Hulu plus lets you binge on
thousands of hit shows anytime,
anywhere on your TV, PC,
smartphone or tablet. Uh,
and that's it for the podcast this
week. Um, I had just an awesome week.
I Know I was just bandwagon,
but it's really, you know,
exciting after all those years
of watching the red sox suck,
to actually watch them now consistently
be this winning franchise and be able to
turn stuff around. And I know they
spend more money than God. Uh,
but it is cool and, uh, I dunno,
I hope it happens to your city.
I hope you guys go on a run,
especially Cleveland, Kansas
City, um, all of those,
you know, I don't, I am all, I'm
only a hater of, uh, you know,
the Yankees, the Canadians
and the Lakers. And even then,
I respect all of those teams
as much as I give him shit.
I definitely respect him. But,
uh, I don't even hate the giants.
I actually love the giants
and I'm hoping that they, Ya,
I don't know. I just, I don't,
I don't have that thing in football where
I have like a team that's the Yankees.
I mean,
I love that the jets beat the saints
this week because that means that uh,
oh, Foote fellows, foot fetish guy down
there. I'm forgetting his fucking name.
Rex Ryan.
He has a chance to keep in his job.
You know,
I don't want him on ESPN
analyzing football games.
I want him to as a patriots fan,
I want him right where he is.
Head coach of the New York jets.
All right,
that is the podcast for this week.
Congratulations to the 2013 red sox.
I wish I watched all throughout the year,
but I didn't.
I'm just a bandwagon guy and I'm going
to wear the red sox championship hat and
I'm going to laugh when you guys give
me Shit because I am bandwagon. However,
I am diehard Bruins Patriots and I'm
actually going to get the NBA channel
because a package because cause
the Celtics are rebuilding and um,
I wanna I wanna see if
they can do it again.
They can rise from the ashes and buy some
more free agents and see what happens.
But, um, I actually, you know,
went to the clippers warriors game and
I had a great time and the warriors look
like a really exciting team as to
do the clippers. So, Eh, fuck it.
What am I going to fuck up the Ravioli
again this week? I watched some hoop.
All right. That's it. Hey, by the way, uh,
I'm going to be at the Rangers
Penguin's game. All right.
Stone Sober Madison Square
Garden this week. Uh,
it should be a great game. All
right. If you're not watching hockey,
give missing out. Go fuck yourselves.
They'll talk to you next week.